[Musique]
amy winehouse
mik
là
[Musique]
n'est ce pas
solide et nous
c'est bon
les six
[Musique]
il va à grimaldi c ou bonsoir deuxième
étage en europe la deuxième nation la
nasse
l'ami avis d'assaut
ça
on va finir de ma mère je peux sauter
dessus tout de suite ou comment tu
t'appelles tu es bon jour au québec
cette année
toi tu es bah oui tu m'as les noms et
fonctions et que si on faisait des
photos charest comme le dit si tard et
des patrimoines ash ouais ça marche tout
le temps c'est ça l'idée on me voit pas
mais la beauté
paris 1er comme c'était plateau au
tournage je commençais deviez français
est pas prise
quel rêve lisent ces studios comme
s'appellent dans ses studios
j'ai alors est à réétudier sa coté à la
faune et à la flore mon français henri
blanc non j'adore
oui écrit très séduit par les femmes qui
ont un accent italien
tu peux me croire
ces cas là la première question il n'y a
pas de question je te regarde là pour le
moment sur un chèque au nom du peu de
touches te regarde s'est pas marié toit
non c'est pas mariés non
ces célibataires pas trop c'est vous
parlez avec vos vies sentimentales
non pourquoi c'est catastrophique bah tu
donnes trop at on travaille c'est normal
il donne trop de temps à ton travail oui
tout moi je suis né pour mon travail me
donc c'est au détriment de de ta vie
privée qui en souffrent sinon je déteste
parler de ma vie privée
le résultat faire un petit peu tu dois
me dire un petit peu à la jsk petit
petit petit petit j'ai brûlé les mecs
aussi des français allez je les ai quand
j'étais enfant
enfin soit 18 ans et je l'avais pas que
manger
j'ai rencontré des mecs se battait comme
soliste bagaté langues
mauvais mauvais jeu contre des mecs
mauvais je me suis brûlé sa vernet est
là je pense à quai moi je dois donner le
mot énergie sur le travail plus je donne
mes registre travail pour travailler me
donne un mois pour les choses alors ces
îles à ma mère que l'habitat durable
mais à mon frère j'ai trois frères plus
grande et moins donc les gars ont su que
nous très jeune les garçons puisque tu
as fait tes frères à la maison oui les
hommes voilà ce que j'aimais mon frère
avec la fille fait pas les aînés après
dix années n'ont imaginé
oui et moi je suis pas quelque chose je
ne suis pas capable de choses à je suis
né comme ça non avec 3 fait mon
traitement
mon père et ma mère je suis toujours
chez vous ça vous allez me connaissez
les produits
je vais parce que j'avais la couture
comme ça non gvt est un fait naître
catholique ça donne plus de plaisir à
faire dépêcher parce que quelqu'un qui
n'est pas catholique il connaît pas le
plaisir de c'est parce que je suis
capable et si nous les catholiques on a
un avantage c'est quand on fait des
pêcheurs j'espère 30 ans
quant à quai mais entre vista le bouton
de jouer bout'chou sml la ciao ciao qui
était mon frère moi je suis toujours
régime toujours régime
je fais toujours la gymnastique je ne
crois pas les mots collègues et que
l'éditeur moi je mange des couches et
vosges pour des problèmes je suis
toujours régime et l'oma n'ont jamais
fait ah ah ah si non tu sais que ça
extraordinaire états unis si l'amour de
toi moi ça y est là quoi je suis fou
d'amour pour toi je te jure je veux pas
faire un show de télévision en france et
succès formidable fille comme ça non
mais tu extraordinaire
moi je ne connais pas peut-être tout
fait causer avec tous les filles et pas
du tout mais pas du tout mais croit pas
ça tu peux a brûlé les mains non mais
peut-être que tu fais tu fait qu'aussi
avec toutes les filles mais pas du tout
jamais ça m'arrive ça ça m'arrive une
fois tous les dix ans getac crois tu
peux me croire que la raison de croire
ça m'arrive une fois tous les dix ans et
un flash ça c'est rien
la tigresse c'est un lien avec la nuit à
paris quand je pense que tu vas dormir
tout seul ça me pouvais tu vois non mais
franchement
thello un petit peu mais je suis entouré
non je vais pas besoin parce que tu dis
p louche et logiciels osaka mais appelle
l'hôtel où il loge que louche on dit
pelloux gens pensaient aussi des belges
ont dit tout le temps d'accord une
petite touche toute la journée on dit ça
et c'est aliens dans tout cela mais
qu'est ce que tu as la pelouse une
alliance à une alliance est la même
liang laïcisme assez de mon père oui
c'est mon père mais m et pourtant je
sais qu'il veut venir la main droite je
sais pas non c'était marié c'était bon
la gauche ya quand même bien quelqu'un
que tu aimes bien
l'abbé tieghem mais moi je n'aime pas
c'est normal
mad men a même bondi moi je vais y aller
moi oui je te laisser travailler
merci et très sympathique à est vrai
c'est parce que j'ai du sang italien
nits médecin dis moi tu sors à présent
tu sors pas tu étais sorti avec moins
bas plus tard là je vais te laisser
travailler apprendre était marié oui
mais ma femme a appris deux choses à ses
bellissima perron capriccioso karine
issime apéro capriccio mado poteau tommy
piatti négatifs assure finta dessibourg
propre héros sont compétents sont nos
grands hôtels et d'autoroutes et bint et
mado poteau thiam en diamants
au fond ce kg ça on dit marc bideau et
l'hydraulique italie héros permis
basterra quêtes ou celui d'un port et
subito me calmer leurs capitaux that
make up leach hybride honey honey cause
à monaco hadayamet piot preciosa et des
topics sommes encore en amont et
capriccioso malavita belle la seconde
[Musique]
guy bagages en espagnol il n'a pas
appris à nager avec ma gueule à rester
seul d'amendé demi panaché charles
charles gianni raconter l'histoire du
cochon
non c'est quoi c'est à 100 billets qui
croise un cochon et lui ça va mieux
oui la chimio hong kong star
pas sûr que tu attendais
si tu m'a réconcilié avec la chanson
française oui c'est pas un de mes
moindres milite tu reviendrais à mourir
dans un grand boeing bleu de mer je m'en
vais revoir l'hiver mais ces aurores
boréales aux gens du quartier site avait
voyagé à l'eau vers des rivages côtiers
cantier on bouge entre participent
aujourd'hui on dort et montréal
bangkok montréal avant comme kyoto
couvait bon appétit
car si écarté j'adore sur le bois redon
sur le web
comment c'était mon pays ce n'est pas un
pays c'est comme en tribune c'est jean
vigneau ça c'est comment ça n'est pas un
chemin c'est la neige blanche cette
année je me relis mon père a fait
bâtiment de sept étages et pony games
est moins palpable
[Musique]
hussein s'il voulait j'ai découvert un
jour à d'albums tu vas voir 14 15 ans la
boxe appelé la francofête
et ça a été enregistré dans les plaines
d'abraham avec québec et il y avait l on
soit que l'album s'appeler j'ai vu le
loup le renard le lion voix mais ces
pays gilles vigneault félix leclerc
charlebois au concert de grand fayt
francophones du québec y avait quatre
cent mille personnes et tous les trois
lâchers comme le font sur scène ils
faisaient tout comme les méchants dont
il n'est pas une bd de problème on va
tout faire pour les gens s'approchant
des salaires par sourire beaucoup
voyaient plus beau
mais sous l'effet des prises
il était toute en fleurs tout le monde a
foncé qu'antisémite infligée il s'est
mis plus tôt il s'est mise à crier
monsieur emporté beau chez moi pour tous
les goûts ne commence félix leclerc qui
n'est pas fort je tiens lis on fait
courir de fausses nouvelles français
contre onze je co 2
mais comment toi et moi
le plaisir doublé
temps
je veux sentir ton coeur d'un boukari
dont bulls
bon signe
je me contre nous
on songe ou co
[Musique]
après la main
la boîte est ce que pour pas qu'on voit
son gars il est perdu il est ailleurs
mais sous un ciel orangé dans un verre
de tennessee vahid est plus là dottori
il s'en fout de la guitare et s'en fout
[Musique]
une demi heure trois quart d'heure il
s'en fout il est plus là et d'ailleurs
ils ont pété dans des mails ou sont
entrés dans paris soit par ici ça part
en vrille
les loups sont entrés dans paris
ça c'est joli charmante et demi
et l'eau sont entrés dans paris
cinquante élus parisiens ni benjani
jana jonas j'arrive dans la boîte de
jazz
histoire d'oublier un peu le coup de ma
vie les gardes burger des bébés c'est
pas un habitué
sûrement pas un amoureux de dizy
l'ochestre s'installer professionnels
comme c'est moi qui serai aigüs koné
charlie mingus part que je connais par
coeur et puisse le nom de davis aussi
j'ai connu aussi j'aime tous les succès
de duke ellington tous les standards
oscar peterson
lionel un top management chez verizon ok
ok je voulais te dire
que je t'attends tu perds ton temps tu
savais comme je t'attends je t'attends
je t'attends tout temps
ce soir demain n'importe quand comme
quelqu'un qui apprend que vais je faire
ouais sait-on que sera ma vie mais bon
de tous ces gens pourraient hakim maddi
faire maintenant que tout est fini
j'aimais beaucoup ce n'est pas parce
qu'ils seraient pas ce qu'ils sont
devenus vieux les contes chansons
françaises d'hier chanson française les
phares tac est donc je sais mais mon
coeur est tranquille
et les vies c'est que la boucherie de
bleu pour ce qu un miséreux ce qu'un
malheureux cherche encore et encore
tiens clientes ou brûlés
[Musique]
les vrais mâles
des cartes les pour atteint
[Musique]
l'inaccessible étoile
à tort
cette fois théorique et est efficace
oui celui-ci on savait le laisser à ce
qu'on va faire c'est laisser ça c'est en
doublettes est énorme
bynum une andouillette sans frites c'est
un peu comme comment dire comme le vamos
en ses nouveaux seins et quoi c'est ça
pas grand intérêt
enfin bon je vais me fâcher avec tout le
monde c'est pas grave
l'ensemble est rigide en avant je suis
jeune et que les chansons
je demandais pas les choses et les bois
et l'eau chaude
ma joie par dessus les toits oui vous me
donnez vous chainel et si les s'est
embrassé sur la joue
je ne voudrais pas faire les chemins des
potagers payer cher pour du bon talent
on oublie pas non mais j'espère qu'une
ariégeois différents verticaux veut pas
[Musique]
hélène si je t'écris attention mesdames
et messieurs dans un instant
sap a commencé installez vous dans votre
photo et bien gentiment prince à 4.20
partaient tous les projecteurs vont
s'allumer et tous les acteurs vont
s'animer en même temps les filles nous
avons matin et plein de chansons comme
le sommet nous allons entrer dans votre
maison
notre pari bros
notre vin est bon si vous le voulez
c'est de bonne guerre que nous
partageons on dit que certaines demain
on dirait que c'est jane dominé avec
nous
on dirait que ça dégèle de marcher dans
la boue
on est à james dean air avec nous ce
chalet le long des rues comme un enfant
perdu ma j'avais fait j'avais 3
[Musique]
à toi paris 8ème a pris de tes bras
le nombre d'abonnés
[Musique]
je l'avais prédit la chanson merde mais
comme les rois mages en galilée
suivez des yeux l'étoile du berger ou tu
vibres et nous tu iras j'irai vis d'elle
comme une ombre
jusqu'à destination plaise au ciel que
s'ouvre mes fenêtres le matin au bord
d'un étang bleu pour les haussiers le
cul rien ne nous est dans ce monde avant
tout comme les rois mages en galilée
regard d'amour il est déjà 10 ans voit
son essence vraiment acquittons porte et
tu t'en vas de chaos parmi ces milliers
de gens
c'est un moment mis des gants pour
marcher dans la forêt où on trouverait
plus normal d'aller se coucher seul dans
les jeunes et de la dire pas d'ours est
une chose quand le matin mais chaque
fois c'est pareil c'est quand on est
derrière les carreaux
oui quand on travaille depuis que le
ciel est bon il fait bon rire oiseaux
des glaces il faut mon besoin d'elle
même la fondue de l'entrée où s'est
arrêté sur me dis moi ce moment très
précis où tu m'a dit je vais partir et
puis tu es parti j'ai cherché où le
repos - j'ai vécu comme un robot maison
qu une honte on est venus n'ont remonté
ma vie
là où tu vas tu trouveras des tissus
avec edmond qui rassure le bota mouche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
alors ton 9 ans né au nab alors j'en
étais resté ou bas lucette la lucette
voilà d'accord enrobant
paru il ya six mois à peu près sept mois
voilà sur la fan de céline et là le
intelligentsias parisienne le
politically correct a réagi comment
très mal comme toujours puisqu'ils sont
politically correct c'est ça non
que la merde ans tu peux rencontrer
regarde jean edern hallier qui a été
ostracisé pendant des années moi quand
j'étais arrivé jean edern hallier dans
lunettes noires ont traité de nazi et
puis maintenant j'ai une alliée il est
devenu un mec vachement fréquentable
parce qu'il est devenu militant mais
c'est pas mal quand tous ses moyens type
qui m'a envoyé mon anagramme de ces de
marc edouard nabe saf et anar de bec
d'amour bon qu'est ce que je vais boire
mois
s'il vous plaît
arrivé là très énervé tombe savall hervé
ouais
ouais bon
y aller voir les films de ramallah comme
si aussi ouais c'est
siboza je suis quoi je devrais me mettre
une casquette aller voir les films je
suis vraiment content mais je connais
pas bien
alors que moi je sais pas encore non là
je n'ai pas bien nous non pas du tout le
dernier bien tu vois parce que comme je
disais c'était ça frôle le documentaire
moi j'ai beaucoup à nanterre c'est la
salle intérieure du documentaire qu'on
peut vraiment faire de la fiction
aujourd'hui vraiment ça j'y crois très
fort
et là il est allé faire un petit film
avec une voix off qui est qui et qui vit
un de ses textes sur un endroit assez
spécial dont je parle aussi dans mon
journal intime qui sont derrière
l'ambassade de russie où il ya des mecs
qui se branlent au jeu là ce soir d'un
visionner ce soir c'est bon alors on
pourra y aller ensemble
moi ce qui m'a coûté ce soit les filles
sont en normandie auxquelles on peut
aller les chercher
moi c'est intéressant quand le quand les
essuie-glaces enlève le sperme sur les
pare brise mais aussi la télé
latéralement il les a montrés ce ballon
devant les dans les portières oui il me
fallait pas que les photos ébranlé le
l'individu veut souvent là il ya tous
les jours des gonzesses qui viennent
avec des mecs
ah ouais quand les décapotables
non on est voitures fermées ils
préfèrent des rogues séquelles quel
genre de fille qui viennent ici les
fribourgeoises contre l'australie après
de belles bagnoles des riches et vous
quand vous faites ça vous avez
l'impression de vous taper des
bourgeoises un peu la pression c'est top
puis c'est tout ouais c'est une façon de
soleil tapait quoi c'est pareil la même
chose c'est jouissif de se taper les
bourgeoises voix jouissif loi oui et non
ça dépend où penelope et c'est votre
seule sexualité ça non
j'ai des rapports normaux avec d'autres
filles bien sûr mais ça c'est un truc en
plus
un truc à part qu un peu spécial il ya
longtemps
ça vous a pris avec déjà dix ans vous
vous lassez pas non
vous vous voyez les mêmes qui reviennent
on y boit souvent fait toujours les
mêmes vous finissez par les connaître on
peut les voitures vous reconnaissent
aussi il ya des relations qui se crée
non mais vous une complicité voire une
complicité bonnes relations elle marie
daver de quoi ou le mec avec elle un bon
à rien et regarde des photos et y en a
qui viennent sans jeu l'ol viennent tout
avec un jeu plus peu envieux lecture
mans la plupart avec leurs mecs ils ont
fait l'âge les mecs en général ceux des
ponts sont pas spécialement vieux tombé
sur un vieux de vingt-cinq produite sur
un vieux de 22 avec de 30 ans avec 2 50
hawaï a pas d'âge et près de la gonzesse
les empennages en général a pas d'âge
est très jeune aussi john dont c'est
surtout pour mater les trois jours ouais
et des fois ils sont trois dans la
bagnole ouais je suis rare mais pas
cessé pour voter quand ils sont trop
ouais
ou alors il faut une équipe et cela
jusqu'au 1 aller jusqu'au bout jusqu'à
la baisse du tout ses clips des frères
vont rentrer dans la bagnole
chez nous des fois oui vous les baisers
sur 10 sur 10 vous rentrez comme une
fois dans la voiture beaucoup ça vous
manquerez si vous ne faisait plus ça
non on fait quoi dans la vie comme ça ah
ouais vous prenez du pognon des fois les
liens qui vous payent pour enfin voiture
combien les pas de dépôt de taille aps
sa peine 55 son sac
église et saison jamais de plus
l'attrait l'ont toujours des partenaires
tels pas toujours
souvent le poids des fois elles sont
vraiment à poil normal quoi elle se sent
pas millet pour venir ici
non pas spécialement ils y arrivent
normalement dû appuyer normal comme une
femme eux et non que vous avez eu envie
de revoir une fois
ouais il a plusieurs mais vous avez revu
en dehors dessinant donc adresse que ici
c'est vers quelle heure le mieux le pot
d'heure avant les boîtes et les sorties
des boîtes points
bonne soirée merci bonjour ses
conclusions champagne champagne
seulement aux bouteilles seulement une
bouteille de champagne j'ai pas de gp
qu'est-ce qu'on va boire alors alors à
peu vous devez un bouclier fiscal est un
bon tir au muscle qui serait on non non
non non pas d'alcool
non mais donnez-moi un kir au muscadet
ouais c'est sûr ça me faire du bien sans
moi marc édouard si tu fermes les yeux
laquelle musique elle
10 de jazz tu entends toujours le même
si en ce moment parce que vous serez
nous vivons une grande année il ya
beaucoup de choses qui sont passés cette
année mais un des plus grands événements
de l'année c'est qu'on a retrouvée et
j'espère qu'un jour vous aurez les
droits pour le passé ou dans votre sur
votre chaîne ou ailleurs on a retrouvé
huit minutes inédites de charlie parker
film et c'est à dire qu'on le voit fumer
une cigarette on le voit se déplacer et
regarder un des maîtres du saxophone qui
s'appelle coleman hawkins et en 1951 et
il joue donc c'est inédit on n'avait
jamais entendu ça c'est prodigieux de
nantes en charge et charlie parker et
dans ce morceau la partie bilan
je le vois bouger ce qui est rare est
toujours instructif moi c'est comme si
aujourd'hui envoyer rembrandt comment
ils pressés de sa peinture sur sa
palette avec ses pinceaux c'est toujours
instructif de voir les gens bouger
les corps sont les essentiels eux
pour les âmes ses doigts de l'autre jour
on était en train de descendre la rue
saint-denis avec sarah white et d'un
seul coup on passe devant un petit bout
en bout y ait un petit bistrot de rien
on entend une musique de jazz on rentre
il y avait des gens assez assez de
terres menacées qui était pété à la
bière et qui regardait un mec qui joue
et du sax à la perfection est un type
qui jouait de la guitare comme jimi
hendrix avec les cheveux comme comme
brian jones
jean morer
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
bisous bisous bisous encore
[Musique]
mais
il
[Musique]
je
à
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
n 1
c'est
[Musique]
là
et
noël
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
si tu es j'ai jamais compris pourquoi
les gens étaient pour le suffrage
universel et contre l'audimat
parce que c'est exactement la même chose
et effectivement si tu es par le
suffrage universel tu ne peux pas
critiquer l'audimat
et si sébastien a fait 50% de parts de
marché ben oui c'est comme s'ils règlent
plus en plus tu me tues tu sais que tu
connais chez adam à côté de moi je suis
pas numéro
oui mais voilà et on accuse le numéro un
là mais il attend venir j'étais de garde
c'était comment un an raconte nous
battons c'est ils y étaient tués ce
jour-là vous dis moi c'est un jihad dans
ces moi j'ai des relations
j'ai une théorie chez les boîtes de nuit
c'est finalement entre regard ddt dans
une boîte de nuit
tu bois du champagne ou bien tu boit du
whisky
tu as le choix entre regarder des gens
danser des gens pc je préfère garder des
jambes il n'y a pas photo il ya pas
photo puisque de toute façon les gens
qui sont en train de danser ils pensent
qu'ils vont baisser autant les voir
directement baiser donc c'est adam à la
moldavie à danser la première d'une
nouvelle génération soit là dans dix ans
les boîtes de nuit ce sera des boîtes
échangistes
il y aura les échanges et des exhibo et
y aura les gens qui sont là en train de
boire du whisky en train de la gare des
baisers je suis ton fou de voir des
grossesses danser alors tu préféré les
voir à poil en train de se faire baiser
il ya des boîtes où ça peut arriver
évident qu'ici c'est la tienne ça te
dérange pas de l'avoir avec un riche en
échanges is much et à échanger
donc je sais mais la boîte d'échangisme
c'est un peu réducteur c'est un peu
limité il faudrait que ça soit plus
celle qu'on puisse aller jusqu'à jusqu'à
retrouver sa propre femme à qui on donne
rendez-vous la barre puisque comme un
héros qui a grandi à temps a dit adam a
dit grégoire a dit quand je vois ma
femme ce perso tu es par douze mecs ça
m'excite je deviens le vagin de ma femme
c'est quand même une phrase adam est ce
qu une grande phrase adama trouve un
petit peu faible
[Musique]
keira accès aux à skyrock
tyrone
[Musique]
c'est un échec cette porte bordel qu'est
ce qu'il fait et 38 sort bordel [__]
c'est pas quel foutoir
il ya quelqu'un là dedans allô allô
quiétude qui était à la barre quel âge
as-tu où es-tu 27 ans paris bon je te
présente thierry ardisson il s'agit mais
j'entends rien
tiens devenu ton truc là puisque l'hôtel
je pense qu'il fait voilà allô allô allô
ouais ça lui sert dix ans ça lui fait
plaisir
ouais tu écoutes maurice toi rarement
way est rarement je t'écoute maurice
pardon pourquoi tu l'écoutent
ben en fait je me demande
particulièrement la manière donc ça
montre assez de choses à faire quand
même
ouais mais c'est sûr tu n'avais rien à
faire albert ce soir pas grand chose est
ce que tu penses qu'un type comme moi on
peut l'utiliser comme un loisir à ce que
tu penses que je vais supporter moi de
là où je suis imaginez qu'un type comme
toi qui ce soir s'ennuyait qui au lieu
de jouer au tennis en son téléphone et
m'appellent est ce que tu penses que je
peux être à ta disposition albert
demande pas si le tennis c'est génial je
t'ai poser une question est ce que tu
penses que je vais supporter ça et moi
arrêter va le savoir côtoient
lâchez clair il soit encore
un look et manage tout prix alors oui
c'est nerveux inquiet du terril
d'innovant paris oui je rêve ou de
paraître occuper en fin de rencontre en
fait que quand j'étais petit j'avais une
certaine une certaine perception des
choses j'avais une perception assez
féerique assez subjectif des choses et
maintenant j'ai 19 ans et je n'arrive
plus à avoir cette perception est ce que
ta maman comme tout j'aimerais pouvoir
retourner à cette perception
je sais pas c'est déjà arrivé en face je
me prends un peu la tête pour rien mais
oui c'est sûr tu t'ennuies alors je
m'ennuie pas du tout aujourd'hui les
gens les ans sont comme ça toute l'année
mon fils ils se disent toujours qu'est
ce qui pourrait me donner de
l'importance dans ma propre tête mais
qu'est ce qui pourrait me faire exister
j'ai pas mon bonheur parce que mon
bonheur il est bon il est là je me lève
le matin j'ai mes deux bras et deux
jambes sedan donc c'est super tout va
bien donc ça ce n'est pas intéressant ça
ça ne me met pas en valeur
or qu'est-ce que j'ai qui va pas il ya
des mecs mais y'a rien tout va bien
paris se disent mais [__] je suis sûr
je vais trouver je ne souviens de ces
gens je rencontre de temps en temps le
samedi quand on est ensemble qu'on
bouffe un morceau il ya toujours
quelqu'un qui connaît un mec qui est
mort mais qui est malade et tout de
suite on se dit tiens ce type là est
intéressant et un moment quand on
s'appelle cyril se dit ouais tiens mais
attends quand j'étais petit tout était
magique tout était merveilleux tout cela
maintenant je tout n'est pas magique et
merveilleux donc ça ne va pas n'est ce
pas cyril c'est quoi que j'aimerais
j'aimerais pouvoir encore être non tu
crois pas que tu aurais mieux à faire
que penser des trucs comme ça c'est un
fait
cheryl sert il oui ça me fatigue
ouais ça me fatigue comprends pas
non je m'en fous je veux dire quand
j'étais môme il ya plein de trucs que je
savais faire des trucs tu savais pas
faire aujourd'hui me suis un peu plus
grands il ya des trucs que je sais faire
des trucs que je sais pas faire rescue c
est ce que ça mérite une réflexion
nocturne des pas géants personnellement
je crois pas vive la vie relève ne sert
il pas le téléphone toi ah bon pas le
téléphone à vue maintenant qu'à 19 ans
tu sais téléphoner c'est magique
alors qui va là je te prie
[Musique]
les corrections de ne rien rater de
linda hardy tube abonnez vous y mettez
un peu de bleu